[Musique]
on ne la voyait déjà pas beaucoup à
l'écran on risque de la voir encore
moins non non non non non et oui alors
que karine ferri co-animé danse avec les
stars en 2018 aux côtés de camille
combal cette saison la production avait
décidé de lui confier l'animation de
l'after seulement niveau pression en est
la
rétrogradation que l'animatrice n'a
pourtant pas vu d'un mauvais oeil je
suis la seule femme à être à la tête
d'une deuxième partie de soirée sur tf1
j'ai la chance d'avoir mon moment un
mois de détente et des changes pourtant
selon le magazine public ce changement
de case pourrait être un pas de plus
vers la sortie car la première chaîne
aurait déjà trouvé sa remplaçante
et sept remplaçants de fait elle aussi
partie du programme puisqu'il ne
s'agirait tout que de la danse ou ceux
qui naissent van damme s'est appréciée
par la production
alors voilà de quoi mettre un peu plus
de tension dans les coulisses pour cette
fin de saison qui devrait se tenir le 26
novembre prochain
alors qu'est ce qui se passe avec tarif
bernès était toujours des infos moi je
suis triste pour elle parce que c'est
vrai que c'est une humiliation c'est une
suite de mesquinerie et là ils ont
organisé un mini ils ont organisé un
casting dans son dos erres que déjà
n'était plus à l'animation elle était
sur le coteau est à dire alors à quand
on est à dix c'est à dire que la la
derrière il ya un casting mais oui ils
ont fait un casting sans la prennent
très vite compris que si les émirats et
seconde zone absolue hu a pas à dire
attendez il y avait personne dans le
casting puisque voir quelle il faut
lancer des boutades la mécanique
et surtout
avec candice pascal abinan dont tu te
fais les émissions essence a une qui a
fait au moins un mort m est une
célébrité sommet non non non formidable
les autres il faut renouveler mais mme
et aride elle a encore sa place sur tf1
suis désolé langeois pas toujours sans
les prêts vous soyez prêt proposé
quelque chose à karine autant avec les
ir bien sûr monsieur en temps
professionnel nommé rock ce qui était
très triste pour elle c'est quand même
si on regarde foutez de la gueule de qui
sait jamais si on regarde toute la
lumière signalé magnifique voir mais si
on regarde toutes les émissions
auxquelles elle a participé oui elle a
été rétrogradée à chaque fois elle elle
co-anime et dale c'est là que l'after
les bêtises les animer la l'equanil ou
alors c'est christophe beaugrand l aider
dans the voice et les plus denses
devrait y sont qu'elle se fasse
respecter donc par fierté chance qu'il
devrait partir elle cartonnerait sur nos
chaînes elle est très populaire à
l'issue les prime de tf1 déjà sur
d'autres cultures quart temps 28 ans ne
tienne et d'ayants voit la cartonnerie
souris c'est lui il ya plus de place
tiens lui la plus désir pour karine
ferri oui c'est sûr alors si tf1 n'a
plus désir procure une terrine à minsk
quand on lui en vie des produits mais ce
qui est très belle personne ce qui est
du rdpc dans ces conditions d'avoir
l'air détendu et en pleine nuit à l'aise
et bien c'est donc c'est plus facile de
passer un casting un peu en outsider et
deux de s'imposer mensuel c'est toujours
comparer ce sont des rumeurs public
parce que moi j'ai eu une aide van damme
tout à l'heure par téléphone qui m'a dit
je n'ai passé aucun mais c'est alors
peut-être que le fait dany mais parce
que samedi elle a animé les le tictoc de
danse avec les stars on va peut-être ne
s'était pas un essai un peu négligé mais
y'a eu aucun casting officiel on en iran
groupe nommé cyril vous êtes un je vous
comprends pas car immigrés est très
belle et très sympathique mais vous
pouvez pas de ça chez un juge du 'carry
trade' défend là non c'est l'injustice
est pas vrai procès doit commencer par
une furie du nord dont les yeux non pas
du tout mais je crois franchement série
faut être honnête est très jolie s'est
elle est sympathique jalousie la place
du championnat turc vous dire j'ai pas
débattue et bien tf1 nature reprend moi
ça je travaille avec et j'aime beaucoup
public malien qui vous tf1 mais tf1 la
chaîne où le chef de magasin non
y'a pas shopping
racheter encore du barrage à linselles
alors dites-nous et rien à mardi j'avais
acheté la chaufferette hivernale une
fois les derniers ou non mais je veux
dire qu'elles excluent pas beaucoup
public mais ça c'est une bêtise il ya
mais ya pas de cascades huit mois là où
il n'y a pas eu de casting je vous le
promets biatch casting était autant
d'amis n'a pas été casté et ça c'est des
bruits de couloir savait déjà un an que
ça traîne mais elle n'est pas du tout du
tout pour le mans évincé alors oui mais
c'est vrai qu'ils l'ont testé elle a
plein d'endroits et qui a peint en panne
l'enthousiasmé phénoménale des
téléspectateurs pour elle laissait alors
pas de sa faute elle est nommée si elle
était bien son dû dans un sondage très
bon dans cet état qui a été battu par
capitaine mario encore on leur dit que
je suis une redif en une redif 5000 à
redire mais oui on en est ce dire où va
la fronde